today we're going to look at a trap in  the cairo con that results in checkmate  in just  six moves white starts with e4 and black  of course plays the caro with c6  knight c3 d5 and knight f3 entering the  two knights variation  of the caro khan here by far black's  most common move is to capture on  e4 white takes back and now black plays  knight f6  challenging this knight in the center  and now the main move here for white is  to actually capture on f6  but white can be much trickier with the  move queen e2  white is actually setting up a very  devious trap  now white threatens to take on f6  forcing g takes f6 so black may be very  tempted to play the move  knight b to d7 but this is a massive  mistake  because white has checkmate in one with  the move knight d6  and suddenly this king has nowhere to go  and the game  is over i'm national master caleb denby  let me know in the comments if you like  this youtube short  and as always subscribe for more